an
ancient horror has awoken from its
slumber
and is hungry for blood shall we see how
many
have fallen into shadow satellite sweeps
of the war zone have uncovered what
appears to be an
underground storage facility but i
strongly suspect
where chemical weapons are hidden so we
need to move fast
brothers in arms or will it be a case of
each man for himself
on the edge of an abyss
your survival depends on the choices you
make
they will be as a compass guiding you
through the unknown
greener than we landed what nightmare
these luckless souls
fallen into keep look out
look out look out for what
one by one their lights
will be snuffed up unless you can find
the means
to save them trapped beneath the earth
swallow you have to move let's go by the
boy
will you find the path to salvation
or be lost in the darkness
forever
we're here at supermassive to talk about
the next game in the dark pictures
anthology
house of ashes i'm joined by exec
producer dan
how you doing hello thank you for
joining us right
so let's start at the very start we're
going to be talking about
house of ashes for most of the interview
but for those that don't know tell us
about the dark pictures anthology
the dark pictures is a series of
narrative story driven
branching horror stories each one is
standalone
they each tell a different story
completely separated from the others but
within the same universe so there is
connection between them
house of ashes is set at the end of the
iraq war in 2003
with links four thousand years ago that
set the story up
so tell us more about the theme and
themes i suppose within
um house of ashes it starts off with a
military unit they've got some new
technology that can
look for weapons of mass destruction
underground they think they've
identified something in the zagros
mountains in iraq
and then as part of that they come into
conflict with an iraqi unit
there's a pitched fire fight and then
the two groups are plunged underground
there's an earthquake of some sort and
it's revealed that there's a hidden
temple underground these big massive
structures but
these different groups they're all
separated um radio contact is lost and
they're submerged in this black
uh darkness we're on god's greener than
we landed
and then they're gonna start hearing
things and seeing things and people are
gonna start disappearing what the [ __ ]
just happened so this time it's a very
real threat
all of the dark pictures games they all
pull something from from real life or
from history from fact
what's the case with the myth or
historical part of house of ashes
so we love looking at um looking at and
reading
myths and legends and stories and doing
our research and we know our fans love
it as well because there's something
that they can link into afterwards and i
love doing that when i'm playing games
or watching movies myself
so this one's set four thousand years
ago the acadian empire
and this terrible evil that happened we
had this self-proclaimed god king
naram sin and he essentially cursed his
people he sacked this temple
and bought famine and devastation to his
own people
and so a lot of the history is lost but
we've we've done a lot of research about
it and then we had a lot of happy
accidents that linked into the story we
wanted to tell
and the fun thing for us is we get to we
get to do our own take on it we get to
twist it and obviously we've made our
own truth
from it at the end of the sneak peek the
trailer we saw
monsters tell us a bit more about what's
going on there the military unit that
you're playing as they don't really know
what they're coming up against
they're not human they're bigger they're
larger they're faster the team aren't
going to know if there's one or two of
them
or hundreds or thousands of them and
that's kind of the threat with this you
know they've got guns
maybe they could try and take one of
them down but maybe there's another one
around the corner or maybe there's a
group of them and maybe they're going to
get ambushed maybe they're like
a cluster exactly as it were
and it's been really fun to work on and
see these things move around and how
horrific they can be
they're different to us they perceive
the world in a different way getting
little snippets of it in the darkness
and was that did i see that was it
something that moved
or is it actually just one of the other
soldiers that's stuck in the catacombs
who's there we like to try and misdirect
people on things you know that did you
see something did you not
and that's a great thing within horror
that you think you're going to be scared
right now and we're not going to scare
you now we'll scare you in a minute
we're not expecting it it's always
coming
yeah always so should we expect a huge
amount of
peril in the game definitely um we love
to do it um
you know it's fun fun for us to work on
it's horrific as it is and it's
we know that our fans love it as well so
yeah there's at least 60
unique deaths and there's a whole ton of
variation on that as well so
merwin and some of the others you're
going to see different things happening
to them depending on how you play out
you know getting ripped and shredded
and torn and because there's a firefight
there's going to be bullets flying as
well and all kinds of stuff
and it's not just the deaths it's the
gore that goes along with it and
you know lots of blood wicked it sounds
absolutely terrifying
i'm in
what differences have you made or
changes have you made to the to the game
player mechanics for house of ashes
we were always evolving the dark
pictures um we listened to a lot of the
feedback from our fans um and and also
our team what they want to do how they
want to push things forward
so we we tried some stuff in in little
hope with um you know
more camera control 360 cameras in
certain parts and we've really leaned on
that again and it really works well
in house of ashes lots of the game you
set underground and so these sort of
corridors which are really tight and
impressive creepy
yeah indeed so so we've had to learn
because you take away the fixed cameras
and that takes away some opportunities
for horror but we've had to learn new
tricks to scare people and
you know ramp up the tension and you
know the chance for jump scares which
you know some people love
we've also got a new torch mechanic so
um you know it's military theme so these
guys can be walking around with weapons
with torches mounted on them we love the
lighting that we do this
really inky black darkness that we have
and sort of the contrast to the bright
areas
and so you're going to need to lean on
that torch to allow you to see
where you're going what the threat is
and that kind of stuff
we've also done things like um added
difficulty settings to this game so
in little hope we added uh you know qte
warning icons as an example and we've
got some really good positive feedback
about that but also some people want to
turn that off
we want to allow you to play the game in
your way so with our accessibility
settings and difficulty settings
if you want to have a more casual
experience you can change those settings
still most of your characters are going
to end up dead but you know that's
that's spoilers yeah
but that's what we come here for that's
okay we can deal with it so i've got to
ask
what was it like working with ashley so
ashley was fantastic
she researched rachel she understood her
when she came on the set which is so
refreshing she knew her inside out
and rachel is a flawed character so she
brought that through so fantastically
the rest of the cast were fantastic as
well when we were looking for joey
shaleem helped me you didn't tell me
this because
you'd flip your [ __ ] we want you to
connect to these characters and
understand them as humans we want them
to seem real because they're real to us
you know we spend a long time designing
them and
and i don't mind if you hate any one
individual character because
you don't like everyone in real life but
maybe you'll like them when you see the
journey they go on
maybe you'll like them once they're dead
yeah and you feel bad about it
differently yeah
but also we want you to save them we
want you to try and take them you know
we know that some people want to get one
killed straight away and that's fine
that's
their playthrough that's what they want
to do but you know can you get everyone
out alive
and save as many as you can it's a lot
of replayability there indeed
so last question favorite scene
favorite scene so um selim
now iraqi soldier and jason colchek one
of the marines that's there
there's a way that that can play out and
a sort of contest between them and
you can make it go in a number of
different ways the enemy of my enemy is
my friend
it's really emotional seeing them film
it i was lucky enough to be there
and they'd seen that come through in
game i think we've got something there i
think that's gold
um and then of course i love scaring
people so i love the jump scares i love
the
the moments of tension uh that we bring
we can't hold you in that moment so
we've got some fantastic jokes in there
as well
to allow you to relax for a moment
before we scare you again
to take your mind off the imminent
threat i like that
dan thank you so much this has been
really cool to talk about and i'm sure
you know
i i'm excited and terrified in equal
part and everyone else is just excited
i'm sure and it's been a real pleasure
to speak to you and i can't wait to get
it into people's hands
you